new year same pandemic with dimensions
that can be hard to put into context if
you had told me a year ago that we'd be
starting 2022
with a fourth wave
i simply wouldn't have believed you but
here we are
you've seen the numbers
how one day's record stands until it's
beaten by the next days with new covert
19 cases topping 500 a day and 3 000
active cases newfoundland and labrador
is imposing tighter restrictions on
gathering limits but the vast majority
of people infected do not need to be
hospitalized and the province is feeling
pressure to open up society and let the
virus run its course
better to limit transmission and spread
out the infections according to premier
andrew fury if everybody does get it
they can't all get it at once and it's
not just because of the beds in the
hospital it's about the human resource
capacity to deal with people in the
hospital especially around
nurses physicians allied health
professionals who are isolating as well
in nova scotia there's a similar
delicate balance january will be a tough
month and i expect that the premier and
i will have some more hard decisions to
make one of those decisions should nova
scotia join other provinces that are
reducing the isolation period to five
days for double vaccinated people who've
been infected but have no symptoms or
should infected workers like nurses come
out of isolation and work if essential
services are in jeopardy the
controversial measure could make sense
according to this nova scotia licensed
practical nurse you wouldn't be able to
be in the break room with anybody else
unmasked you would have to eat you know
by yourself that sort of thing so i
think there's ways to get around it so
that we can have as maximum
amount of people at work as we actually
as we possibly could nova scotia's top
doctor says he'll have more to say about
isolation rules later this week in the
meantime vaccinations are accelerating
nova scotians aged 30 and over are now
eligible for booster shots with 1700
people volunteering to administer the
doses ross lord global news